I love to antique I love to go to
vintage shows I can see something that's
been told and unuseful at the time be
created and come out and be new welcome
it's an honor to have you where do you
guys live Bakersfield California
Wow it's a bit of a hike to Nashville we
are David and Gayle olds we're retired
and in our retirement we came to the
reality and conclusion that we were 82
thousand dollars in debt we had seven
credit cards
most of them maxed out we had been
transferring balances doing various
things we had a second mortgage on her
home to pay for some taxes and we'd
bought a new car so we had $82,000 in
dad we were 65 retired I relied on him a
lot of during the times for finances
because it seemed like if I saw
something I wanted I would leave it up
to him to figure out how we were going
to get it and after I had started a
business an antique business we needed
to kind of communicate better in the
financial department
I always thought throughout the years it
seemed like I could control everything I
could get another job teks an extra
class teach at the college I was the the
king of the credit card balance transfer
I'd find the deal and move it over well
in 2011 as we travel across the country
typically what happens is Gail crawls in
the backseat and curls up with her book
or has a movie that she wants to watch
and me I'm a sort of a radio talk-show
kind of junkie and became familiar with
this Dave Ramsey guy and his message
that he was getting out and how he was
encouraging people and helping people
there was a common interest there I mean
we had talked about our debt and we were
concerned about those things like it's
kind of scary when you think you're
retired and whatever you're making now
that's going to be it forever I mean
you're retired yes you're yet $82,000 in
that it was a real turning point in my
life at that point to realize that we
could be doing something if we were out
of debt our problem was that we were not
out of debt and that was really a
catalyst for me to kind of get things
rolling to go through FPU and we started
through the day's plan the baby steps I
love to go to vintage shows so for me to
have to give up going to those shows was
very hard
I had to also sell off many of my
treasures David told me if you give it
him now you'll have the freedom to go
find those treasures again in July 2015
we came to Nashville into the studio and
we did our debt-free screen all right
David and Gayle they got out of debt
while they were retired and they did it
with cash flow $82,000 paid off in 36
months making 120 a year count it down
let's hear a debt free screen three two
one where dad
yeah
what was important to me was that we
have our kids and our grandkids right
there with us at the time that meant a
lot to me it showed them that they can
do anything in life that they need to do
but they need to be debt free too and so
to me the kids being there with them I'm
getting choked up sorry
it's just thinking about it well you've
not only changed your life and giving a
lot of people hope but your kids your
grandkids are watching yes and they'll
talk about this for 20 years you know
they'll talk about this for 30 years I
remember that time I watched my my
grandmother and my grandfather do that
you know it is never too late to start
never too late to do that here we are
retired I was 65 Gael 63 and we were
kind of cruising along there and we
decided we're going to start this so
it's it's never too late to start and
for us it's wow we look back and of
course we had two regrets like why
didn't we do this when we were 20 or 30
but you can't roll that time back but
you can start now and and for us that
was a new beginning for us and it's been
exciting
you